[Music]
what little I know about German phrases
is that some of them just don't seem to
translate into English yeah I don't mean
nothing you trying none of them do with
Bureau no zero there off the ones - okay
zero up the ones do okay can you teach
me some German phrases could you teach
me now yes because I am very good at
mastering languages oh I'm so excited
for this Conan yeah okay I would tell
you the first one is called you don't
like someone you hang out with and say I
like you I don't like you you smell like
an old like an old shepherd's pie like
stop it you know you smell like an old
shepherd's pie yeah well I'm saying if
you know a man or woman like this yes
yes I do know people like that yeah no
it's yeah yeah yeah call them in the ash
Diegan say it again
ash Geiger ash Qaeda yeah which Mars
Geiger oh wow is that how you say that
was very accurate ash Qaeda yeah whoa
what does it mean that means anus violin
anus violin
[Applause]
if they are acting like a stupid
shepherd's pie it's amazing what they're
hanging out at Harbor too long
nicely done
thank you very nicely done Flula if I
may call you Flula please do it or hair
bored
Oh anything could teach me another
phrase Oh another one is so I am
confused sometimes at the restaurants
you know in Germany if a lady is ruled
with serving the coffee's you're like oh
she is having a not good day yes but
sometimes I've been to Connecticut and
someone is saying they're very smiley
and pouring the drinks good to see you
but it is not real it's not real to like
a why you're doing it you know yeah
pointless pointless wrongly perfect
wrongly how hot that is when someone you
see that in LA to people that are like
real smiley but they don't mean it no
totally pointless what does that mean
may I say the S word with an H in the
after it do you make do beeps exist yes
it's a friendly you didn't have to
translate what was I know it
the part that confused me what was
confused well how it's friendly and mean
no it means like I see what you're
saying it is the fake I got it oh you
look there you look so nice and come up
what smells bad oh you are really a pile
of darm
you